this is tamar hussein reading for
reviewer jordan remay
assassin's creed valhalla embraces its
series heritage and makes for a far more
rewarding experience for longtime fans
as a result though newcomers can still
enjoy valhalla's combat and
emphasis on exploration the game's
biggest narrative ramifications are
largely deep cuts in reference to
previous assassin's creed titles but the
looping structure of the overall
narrative means you can still follow and
enjoy valhalla's story without years of
time spent in the animus
in valhalla you once again play as leila
hassan who's facing the daunting task of
needing to save the world and some bones
are her only clue
on how to do so with no other leads
layla hops into the animus with a dna
sample taken from the remains
allowing her to relive the person's life
this time she'll be aval a viking who
lived during the 9th century
valhalla's modern day plot is the most
focused that this aspect of the
franchise has been in
years there's a clear and present danger
and a nice setup for the through line of
the game's campaign
the concept of fate however the same
care is not extended to layla whose arc
in this game concludes in a way that
doesn't feel earned for a game all about
fate and the consequences of trying to
break free of it
leila ends up feeling like a passenger
more than a driver of her story
thankfully avor more than picks up the
slack with their story
at the start of valhalla aval has a
vision that foretells they will meet a
terrible fate before they can make
proper sense of the more minute details
of the vision however their adopted
brother
sigurd decides to leave norway for
england prompting them to follow the two
re-establish themselves but find their
new home is now located at the
centerpiece of several wars
sigurd sets out to rule over or ally
with each of england's four kings in
order to carve out a safe plot of land
for their clan leaving evol behind to
oversee their growing settlement
[Music]
valhalla's story plays out over a series
of self-contained narrative arcs
by talking to sigurd's wife ranvi evil
can choose which alliances to pursue
next which kicks off a two to three hour
story
upon completion evol returns to ranvi
and reports on what transpired invests
any collected resources into a
settlement and then picks the next
narrative thread once an arc is done
it's done certain characters can come
back in later arcs but that is
very rare to the game's benefit this
means that if a specific narrative arc
has characters or gameplay that you
don't necessarily enjoy
you know that once the arc is over
you're likely never going to have to
engage with that pocket of england ever
again the story will soon move past that
arc and then largely act like it never
existed giving you new characters to me
and mission structures to engage with
however this works against the game too
as anything you like
won't last either the biggest detriment
of the self-contained arcs is the
somewhat shallow supporting cast
because characters typically only stick
around for a few hours there isn't much
time for development
and where there is any it's rushed
romances especially suffer for this
they're shallow and don't have any
meaningful impact on eva or story
avail is the one that bugs the trend of
paper-thin characters in valhalla though
their actual character is already
established you get to push
and prod at their thoughts and actions
evolve wants to avoid their fate
and you get to influence how far they're
willing to go to ensure that outcome do
we have any allies to speak of
or is that your excuse to do nothing the
decisions you make determine how
others view evil which can result in
slight alterations to how certain arcs
and the campaign as a whole end there's
small changes that avoid outright
redefining the timeline of real human
history
instead focusing on giving you the room
to somewhat shape avor into your desired
protagonist
aval's lasting impact or the potential
for it is
also an effective driving force to carry
players through to the end
figuring out how a random viking from
the 800s will save the world in 2020
is an intriguing proposition especially
since valhalla does a good job of laying
breadcrumbs of knowledge and small
revelations throughout its run time to
keep you chasing the answer to that
question
overall this storytelling structure
works out for valhalla its pacing isn't
without its issues the opening hours are
a slog to get through for example
but once it hits his stride with
memorable arcs and more things to do in
the settlement valhalla starts to
exhibit the kind of confidence you'd
expect in the third goal at an
open world rpg style of assassin's creed
it just takes some time to get to that
point
valhalla trusts you to think like an
explorer to put yourself in a war's
shoes as they navigate and attempt to
understand
england this is still a ubisoft game
that's packed with waypoints to follow
for the main campaign and side missions
but in valhalla they're also designed to
encourage you towards discovery and the
game has such
wonderful heartbreaking hilarious and
intriguing things to look for off the
beaten path
excuse me i have a slight pain
do you notice anything on my head
in its combat you'll find the most
agency in how you shape able
earning skill points allows you to
invest in the constellation-like skill
tree the constellation of lines twist
and turn on one another allowing you to
easily double back
invest in more than one tree while also
having different branches of each tree
cross over for more interesting build
opportunities
you can respect aval skills at any time
for free allowing you to easily reshape
them if one combat style isn't to your
liking
regardless of where you put your skill
points avo is a badass raider who deal
wields weapons with a frenzied intensity
valhalla encourages you to fight
aggressively avail doesn't regenerate
health and your healing rations are
limited so it's in your best interest to
end fights as quickly as possible by
assassinating an opponent or disrupting
the tempo of their attacks with powerful
strikes counters or blocks button
mashing will deliver you to an early
grave strategically playing to your
strengths is the only way to succeed
against tougher foes
abilities are where valhalla's combat
gets exciting you can equip
8 at one time allowing you to further
define your ideal build for evil through
both skills and abilities and the way
the game gives you the adrenaline needed
to execute them you're encouraged to
begin fights with a quick
decisive strike and then aggressively
keep up the pressure to win
valhalla also sees you fight your enemy
with social stealth this is used to
great effect in some of the more tense
story arcs where evol
is hunting members of the order of
ancients in cities that the group or an
enemy king controls
forcing them to blend in and parkour
across rooftops until they can close in
on their target
however the parkour mechanics aren't as
good as those seen in some previous
entries so avo can feel a bit clunky
when trying to stealth
it's frustrating when you accidentally
die or get noticed because the controls
are working against you it occasionally
feels like it would have been easier
just to announce yourself
and kill everyone in the vicinity
instead and if you want to do that
that's fine valhalla does not
immediately fail you for being detected
although the assassin's creed franchise
will no doubt continue there is a real
sense of finality to valhalla's main
campaign
valhalla brings together dozens of
narrative threads referencing nearly
every mainline game in the franchise to
tell you how they all connect
in this way the game can feel
specifically designed for longtime fans
however
assassin's creed valhalla is more than
capable of standing on its own
aval is a good hero with an identity
that drives the mystery behind the main
narrative and they shine in the
self-contained arc structure of
valhalla's story the supporting cast may
not shine as brightly but it's easy to
forgive that when exploring england is
so rewarding
[Music]
foreign